sultan bay in cumbria it's nearly 500
miles from carbus bay in cornwall where
the uk will host the g7
but a stretch of coastline which could
prove awkward for boris johnson's summit
ambitions
there's been years of local wrangling
over plans to build on this land at
whitehaven
and open the uk's first deep mine for
coking coal in 30 years
the government faced intense criticism
for failing to intervene
the cumbrian coal mine saga illustrates
the challenges for boris johnson as a
climate leader
he doesn't want to stand in the way of
british jobs but at the same time he's
telling the world to end its reliance on
fossil fuels
on the harbour side we found this group
of friends born and bred in whitehaven
billy worked in cumbria's mines for 25
years and is frustrated
county councillors said open it up then
you're getting other people saying north
closing
then they're coming i'll throw them in
duck
get it up in the asap job says billy
said jobs
work how bad is the job situation here
do you think
desperate desperate the fact is a
hundred and sixty million pounds of
investment in a coal mine
would transform the town its mayor says
speculation that boris johnson wants g7
leaders to help developing countries
decarbonize their economies
doesn't mean whitehaven's mind shouldn't
go ahead
if you set an objective in that
conference to every other country to get
to where this country is now
environmentally we take a huge leap
forward but we've got to have
a balanced approach but
environmentalists say an investment plan
to secure more green jobs is needed in
such a rural county
on the other side of cumbria this
speciality paper mill
employs 600 people
they manufacture paper for high-end
products
produce plastic free packaging and
recycle coffee cups
but the same technology is being
developed to make components for
hydrogen
fuel cells a growth area for a business
dating back to the 1800s
we're ahead of the curb we're building
products that go into
hydrogen we also manufacture products
that go into into wind energy as
uh as well yeah and then a few years ago
those didn't exist but we've invested in
those but we've invested in those
because we felt it was the right thing
to do
but what we're looking for is incentives
investment from the government in order
for other people to follow suit as well
the debate over the coal mine has given
cumbria a moment in the sun
how to phase out fossil fuels of the
past to meet climate ambitions of the
future
lisa holland sky